the uk continues to race ahead with its
vaccine roll out we've ordered over 400
million doses
and we're getting them into people's
arms much quicker than many other
countries too
but the future here still relies of
course on what happens elsewhere in the
world so let's speak now to our first
guest
the who's special envoy on covert 19 dr
david nabarro thank you very much for
being
on the program this morning good morning
how concerned are you
about vaccine nationalism well the
situation is that we have some
excellent vaccines that can stop people
from dying
these vaccines can prevent health
services from being overloaded
and they are a fantastic invention the
world
should be accessing these vaccines in an
equal way because
right now health workers everywhere are
at risk
older people also are a risk and the
only way
to deal with a global pandemic is to get
fair shares across the world
now that's the right thing to do and i'm
really hopeful that world leaders
in the coming weeks will realize that to
have a few countries vaccinating a lot
of people
and then poorer countries having very
limited vaccines
is not really the way to go ahead
economically
socially environmentally and indeed
morally
you're talking about countries getting
their fair share of vaccines
now of course many countries have got no
vaccines they haven't vaccinated anyone
so far
the uk by contrast has got 400 million
doses on order
is that something to be proud of or is
that actually quite selfish
well it's totally understandable nobody
in the world health organization uh
wants to say that people should not be
vaccinated
if there is sufficient available it's
just that at the moment we're in a
a world that has quite a shortage of
vaccines compared with need
and it will stay like that for some
months we've also established a scheme
that enables
all countries to share in the
vaccines that are available they've
asked us to set it up it's been set up
it's called kovacs
over the next six months i'm hopeful
that all world leaders will commit
to a fair sharing arrangement after
we've gone through the present period of
competition to get as many people as
vaccinated as possible
in the end it's one virus affecting the
whole world
we're all at risk we need to deal with
it as a single issue
i think you know if you say things like
everyone deserves a fair share no one
would really disagree with that
i'm interested in what it actually means
in practice so at what point
do you think the uk should look to
potentially at sharing out vaccines with
other countries and who should we
prioritize
the priority for vaccines at the moment
everywhere is
people who are most at risk of getting
severely ill
or dying from this disease those are
people who are susceptible because of
their age or because they've got other
conditions
they're people who are highly exposed
for example because they work in health
care
that's the same situation everywhere and
we need a global policy to do that which
is perfectly feasible
what matters is moment that politicians
believe
that their primary duties to make sure
that they get vaccines to
perhaps everybody in their countries we
think that citizens can actually perhaps
talk to their politicians and say hang
on a bit you know we're actually part of
the world
and we think the first priority is to
make sure that everybody everywhere gets
what they need
we set up a scheme as i said called
kovacs 100 countries are ready to
receive vaccines they've gone through
preparation processes
we've got money to be able to buy
vaccines for them
we're actually authorizing the vaccines
as quickly as we can it's a longer
process
for the wh so than for national
governments so just to um
just to jump in i'm quite keen to
clarify you're talking about the
priority to vaccinate the vulnerable
but then potentially to look at
elsewhere and does that mean then that
do you think that once the uk has for
example
vaccinated those most at risk people
over 50 then
that's when we should start giving
vaccines to other countries i think we
should
i mean of course each each prime
minister
each um group of mps has to form their
own decisions
but it's really a question of of what
makes sense economically
what makes sense for society and what
how it will want to be remembered
in 10 or 20 years time you know do we
want to be remembered as a world where
those who had the cash could afford to
vaccinate their whole populations
and countries that didn't have the cash
had to cope with a possibly
increasing quite dramatically increasing
death rate
among their health workers i don't think
so i don't think that's how
any individual really wants to be seen
when they look at themselves
over the years and it's going to be time
i think for a
national and perhaps even global debate
about what the priorities should be
because in the end we are human and
humans need to be able to work with each
other whatever their race whatever their
ethnicity whatever their wealth
talking about the global response to
coverage you know the fact that no one's
safe until everyone is safe the economic
damage you talk about
is it sensible to limit travel at the
minute particularly of course given
at the new variance and if that happens
do we need to take a blanket approach
rather than just having certain
countries on a red list
i think the main thing about dealing
with covet right now is what we do
inside our
communities and inside our countries
there are two things that really matter
the first is to do everything we
possibly can to avoid
getting the virus and spreading it and
we know what we have to do
to be two meters away from each other
wear masks
isolate when we're sick and of course
practice very good hygiene
and now we've got the extra advantage of
vaccines which will
save lives and also protect health
services
but we also need really strong community
level
locally led public health services what
in britain is called
test trace trees and isolate but that
needs to be
really well working because you can't
deal with this pandemic without being
able to stop spread
and then once those are in place we will
continue to see
the numbers going down last point for me
do you think the uk's test and trace
program is working in a minute
well i think it needs to do better i
think all countries need to get their
test trace treat isolate programs
working really well
with strong local support you see you
can't do
this kind of work of contract tracing
and transmission interruption
if you just do it centrally you've got
to get locally with central support
last point on this one is i just want to
say how brilliant people are doing
throughout the world at the moment on
this pandemic
look at how numbers are coming down in
different parts of europe in the us
right now that they're coming down
because of people's
actions because of the actions of health
personnel
and i think we just have to sometimes
stop for a bit
and say we are doing amazingly we've got
to go on we can't stop
we've got vaccines to help us but in the
end it's our self-discipline
that's going to get this pandemic well
contained it is quite incredible really
when you think about it and
the sort of restrictions that we've all
been living under for the last year or
so no one would have imagined it
um just a short time ago absolutely
extraordinary
um i'm keen to talk a bit about uh the
vaccines
as well and there's a report in the
financial times this morning
about a study of 2 000 people which
seems to suggest the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
is less effective against a south
african variant
it has limited efficacy in protecting
against mild
and moderate disease although important
to note that nobody
seemed to get um severely ill or died
have you seen the study i
know you concerned by it well i saw the
i saw the
press cutting that you're referring to
and yes
you know this virus like every other
virus will
vary a bit like you and me we look
different
and i mean um we and other people look
different so we have variations
and some of those variations are going
to be more viable than others so yes
we're going to see variations emerge
that are particularly dangerous from
time to time we know how to do with this
kind of problem the first thing is
that we use the same precautions as
we're using more generally
uh with regard to distancing and face
masking and so on
secondly we can adapt vaccines that the
scientists are good at doing that
and we will do it just like we do for
flu we'll do the same for coronavirus
so yes variations are worrying and
we have to be very conscious of them but
we know they're going to come and
they're going to go on coming and we
know
that the vaccines will continue to have
to be modified
and that's as it as it will be the
really important thing is that leaders
all over the world need to give support
to outfits like the world health
organization which is the only kind of
organization
that can keep a track on variants as
they emerge in different places
and can help with advice on things like
travel each country will have to work
out its own travel rules
uh that has to be based on their
understanding of the danger
but in the end it's what we do inside
our countries that will determine
whether or not we can keep this virus
contained and under control um
the uk took a bit of a risk didn't it in
delaying
the dose between uh two vaccines against
the advice of the double h so
according to the joint committee of
vaccination immunization the data so far
shows actually quite high levels of
protection after the first dose
undoubtedly saving lives they think has
the uk's approach been vindicated
well certainly what's happening with
this virus is we're learning all the
time
the world health organizations advice on
intervals between vaccine doses
was based on what the manufacturer did
in doing the
what we call phase three trials of the
vaccine
and then wh so in its committees really
has to
work on the basis of what manufacturers
have
told them but is it wonderful that it
has turned out
as a result of the uk's bravery frankly
that this extended uh intervals seems to
be associated with even greater
protection
that's how we're doing kobit at the
moment we're all
learning together different countries
are approaching it in different ways and
and within wh talking with experts from
the uk
we're really really uh but i think
benefiting
from from the willingness of uk
scientists and uk leaders
to tell us very precisely what they're
doing differently and why they're doing
differently and then we add it all up
and we learn from it so yes
i think the uk's approach so far at
least has been vindicated and yes
i think this is a great lesson for the
rest of the world thank you
thank you british scientists yeah
incredible what the
science has been doing absolutely do you
think the whk could actually change its
advice then on the spacing of the jabs
well that depends not so much on wh so
secretariat the people who work in the
headquarters and in the
regional offices it depends on the
committee of experts
some of them british that advise the
that committee is meeting pretty often
at the moment because there's lots of
vaccines coming on stream
and the committee has to look at the
vaccines and it will indeed
look again at the dose issue as a result
of the british experience
that's great and there's more going to
come through about these vaccines
over the coming weeks and months and we
as i say will benefit hugely from
what different countries are doing we've
never had this speed of advancement sort
of
doing and learning at the same time in
my professional life in
anything like this way yeah it's been
quite awe-inspiring really the speed of
it all
um the who is carrying out an
investigation into how kovid
started in china visiting sites the wet
market for example
the wuhan institute of virology has the
wha
received full cooperation from the
chinese
the situation as i'm being told
is that the cooperation has been
exemplary the visit was carefully
planned
all the sites that uh who people wanted
to visit
are being visited there is a openness
for
all kinds of communications to take
place and the work is going ahead
i think pretty well but it's
early days this is detective work and in
terms of
you viewers who study how detectives
work will understand
that you're looking at lots of different
leads and you're trying to pull together
different bundles of evidence
we're anticipating that those this will
take quite a lot longer
i've been involved in studies of earlier
jumps of viruses from animals or birds
to humans
it's never clean and easy there's never
a little signpost saying follow this
path
you have to really work it out and and
so what i'm going to say is
great cooperation and good results so
far
but it may take quite a lot longer to
get the answer
just finally um talk about the detective
work um can you
rule out the theory that the virus may
have escaped from the lab in wuhan
well the thing about theories is that
you have to have them
as a way to set up where the reason why
things might
be occurring in a particular way there
will be theories about how this virus
originated including
uh what we call a laboratory uh incident
and that has to be assessed i can't rule
anything out and i know the team on the
spot
as well as those they're talking to in
in china they're not ruling anything out
either
all options are on the table and
everything will be looked at